hello yes right yes hi how can we help
you yes hi I have a granddaughter 19
years old in Colorado who has tonsil
stones okay yeah it's not uncommon
really where there's either calcified
stones are the the calcified muse of
mucus or solidified mucus in the in the
little cavities inside the tonsils which
gives it hassles more surface area and
of course one of the old ways the old
guys they used to stick their fingers
down there and massage gita' tonsils and
pop those little stones out of there but
does your granddaughter did she have any
other issues does she have any history
of asthma and bronchitis no no other
issues she has had a couple of flu shots
in the past couple of years and your
granddaughter 19 years old has tonsils
in the stones I want you to listen here
okay tonsils in the stones are scuse me
stone to the tonsils stone huh
stones in the tonsils can actually be
caused by lots of mucus being formed and
dehydration that combination if they're
calcified stones it can be caused by
actually raging osteoporosis and babies
babies can be born with osteoporosis is
not an age or gender thing and so people
of any age can have osteoporosis nice to
see these things all kinds of animals in
the zoo's laboratory animals and so
forth and pet animals so it's not an
unusual thing sometimes when you have
raising out to your process your your
parathyroid now your thyroid gland but
your parathyroids will pull calcium out
of your bones and when you have high
blood calcium as a result of this it can
deposit anywhere you can get kidney
stones bladder stones which are called
cystic calculi you get these calcified
stones and your tonsils and so forth and
so we need to look at those things but
do you have any idea how much your
granddaughter weighs is she a big girl
or small or what no pretty small
she your size are bigger yeah he weighs
about 125 but they want to check out her
tonsils well of course they do
and so doctors make their living okay
and so what we want to do is try it
something else first because stones and
your tonsils the stones are the tonsils
are not anything that's gonna make you
sick or kill you they are they're kind
of like pain for arthritis pain is not
arthritis and you can take a painkiller
and relieve the pain but the arthritis
will still get worse so just taking
those stones out of the tonsils they're
not going to solve the problem and are
taking the tonsils out isn't gonna make
things worse because you lose some of
her defenses right so here's a girl
Charmaine she's got some things going on
we're not quite sure what but she has
some things going on 125 pounds 19 years
old what would you do for her to support
healthier calcium metabolism but also to
support her immune system so her tonsils
would be happier well excuse me for her
issues personally I would get her on a
healthy brain and her back again okay he
needs the vitamin d3 obviously mm-hmm
[Music]
pretty much well what about something
like MSM I throw the anytime you need
calcium I'd throw in the MSM okay okay
throw that in I'm in d3 you said okay
and then I would do something topically
what would you have her gargle with to
make the tonsils Hampi er colloidal
silver you got it girl you get an A+
yeah I put a dropper full of colloidal
silver into a shot glass full of water
and let her gargle with that two or
three times a day and then she can
instead of spitting it out and brush her
teeth with it to get the bacterial load
down in her mouth and on her tonsils and
by brushing her teeth and she can
actually massage her tonsils from the
outside she can actually if it doesn't
gagger too much she can take her
toothbrush and kind of brush the tonsils
hmm and take her finger down her throat
and massage her tonsils and it'll pop
those stones out they can be the size of
a pea and I've seen him come out the
size of a pea and so that's not unusual
but let us know how it goes and it
wouldn't hurt again to do a hair
analysis on her get that book rare
husband who cares do a hair analysis and
we'll find out what her mineral status
is
and whether or not she needs some extra
stuff but this will get her started